I am Aaron Harris I'm one of the
partners at Y Combinator I've been
working at YC for a while and I've
gotten to fund a lot of companies and
I've gotten to see a lot of companies
raise money everything from seeds to
AIDS to DC's to weirdo in between rounds
so I'm really looking forward to sharing
some of those lessons but mostly I
really want to learn and chat with my my
guests over here Jeff Lee from Sequoia
just you want to introduce yourself
sure I'm Jeff back in 2004 I was sitting
are you guys taking I think I took
databases in this room but I said a
computer science and then went to Google
or I was at p.m. for Google Maps and
then co-founded a company called
Polyvore I'm CEO there and then in the
last six months I am now at Sequoia
Capital as a partner so Sequoia is a
reasonably well-known venture capitalist
firm it's actually one of the first
firms in the valley one of
longest-running and probably the most
successful what have you learned in just
six months I guess about the people
coming in the door what what
distinguishes off the bat people who
were succeeding or we're going to
succeed in fundraising what do you want
to see yeah so part of the what we look
for it to the COI is we're looking for
really daring founders who want to build
really legendary companies so it's quite
we backed folks like Apple Google Yahoo
Airbnb Dropbox and stripe so part of
what we look for is a founder who's
special in some way or some unique
insight and for me in particular because
you know plea poly war was at eight and
a half year journey of crazy highs and
crazy lows it gets it's really hard it's
just right off the bat like the odds are
against you it's a rational somewhat
irrational to start a company because
the odds are so bad so you need to have
a lot of grit so that's definitely
something we look for and then I think
one of the other things is a really
clear understanding of the problem
you're trying to solve right I think
that's that's something that really
distinguishes people I think a lot of
people spend time pitching the solution
but they don't really explain the
problem and it should be so crisp and
clear what the problem is that you're
solving that the solution almost just
flows
then the third thing we look for is
ideally you're working in a really
really big market where there's line of
sight to look billion dollars of market
cap so those are some of the things that
we look for
all right so for me that breaks down
into like in three different areas right
there's the qualities of the founder
right in terms of the grit then there's
something that that bridges quality and
the problem which is the problem the way
to explain it and then the third thing
is just how big that opportunity so
let's take let's take you through those
so when I think about the first one
that's huge right this concept of grit
and it's really hard to assess that in
someone I mean you look see someone on
the street you don't know if they're
tall you know they may tell you a little
bit about their lives maybe that tells
you they're tough yeah I know how we
think about it we we look at people we
actually want to see how founders
interact right we see how founders talk
to each other and how they think about
the idea that they're working on and
what they've actually done in the past
have they demonstrated fortitude and
toughness how do you how do you judge it
that you spend more time with the
founders usually before investing are
there tests that you make them well if
you drop them in the middle of a forest
with a knife both one you know I think
grit can come from a lot of different
places right like it could come from you
having for example we often ask about
the inspiration for the company right is
it something that you're really
passionate about that drive you that you
have to solve this problem or there's
something you just thought would be a
good business idea but like getting
through the roller coaster you mean it
needs to be there's got to be something
that gets you through each of those
really difficult moments so sometimes
it's because you just care about the
problems so much and there's an
inspiring story they're like you're
solving a problem you have your family
had something that shakes you in your
life so that that's one form of grit
then there's like you said there's
people who have demonstrated continued
ability to like just run through walls
and break down problems and sometimes
that shows up in previous work history
previous things that they've done and
then there's also another form of grit
which is just I mean sometimes it shows
up in completely naive optimism and so
sometimes it's almost better to be a
little naive anemic
about something because you don't know
how hard it can you just keep going is
just very positive outlook and sometimes
it comes from like a chip on your
shoulder we just like we need to prove
yourself like if something is driving
you underestimated your whole life and
so you just keep going to come desire to
prove yourself so those are some of the
different forms that grit can take or
the founder how do the founder convince
you that they have those things do they
tell you the story okay so we always try
to dig in and try to find out what the
inspiration for the company is so that's
that often did Kelly and then you just
with your interactions with someone you
can kind of start to ask them about
their background what they did before
you know is this they some people with
starting companies from an early age
some people have worked on multiple
businesses those are some small signs
but the end of the day a lot of is also
just sounds like for the investor that
you're working with and whether they see
themselves working because you have to
remember like great companies take you
know I think on average it takes about
eight years to exit so when you and your
founder when you Beckett
okay the IPO is now something like 11
years yeah I meant exit so even just a
quick write but you know it's you're
partnering with a person who you're
going to be like you're it's a long-term
relationship you're getting into
especially what you start to get to your
series a and B so you want to find
someone who you have good fit with like
it's almost like you're just someone can
be married to for 10 years except can't
get divorce because very hard to like
you can kick your investors off your cap
table very easily so something they're
really important to think about as you
prioritize picking an investor so you
kind of have to spend a little bit of
that time I guess dating and getting to
know each other like cents that's a
super good point this idea that you
can't kick someone off the cap table
people I think often cavalierly take
money because they say oh look I just
need some money oh this person offered
me money we can always get these
questions from founder saying oh this
random person just offered me 10 50 100
200 thousand dollars like people do
crazy things I'm fat leading and one of
the hardest things to do at seed at a at
B is decide who it is that you're going
to take money from now I'd say
if you get to decide you're actually in
pretty a pretty good situation because
the first rule is get the money you need
to run your business now if there are
more people offering you money then you
theoretically have room for then you
start to get choosing how do you build a
competitive dynamic in a round how do
you get people interested now you're all
hopefully starting small companies and
that are going to be startups that are
going to get big so one day you're going
to want to go out and convince a whole
bunch of people you're going to be the
next Google so how do you build a
competitive dynamic in that fundraising
so I think first of all you you can't go
into fundraising as like a casual side
thing that you do 20% it's actually
better to just be really dedicated to it
and just like all right I know it sucks
because I have to step away from running
my business but I'm going to go all in
and just work on this process and you
kind of think about it as the process
and time it so you have conversations at
the right time and I think you want to
prioritize like the people that you talk
to based on how much you want to work
with them time sort of maybe the
likelihood that you might be able to and
just work your way through but you know
you can also just kind of tell I think
when you have conversations with
investors like this is someone who I can
imagine working with for the next ten
years this is someone who I cannot visit
but you'll start to feel that click but
you really just it's all about timing it
together and almost running almost if
you're trying to run a competitive
process right and you have to I think be
subtle about letting people know when
trying to set timelines and milestones
like you know I'm hoping to get this
done by this date I think being clear
about your expectations helps a lot
setting that timeline saying I'm going
into second conversations like a few of
them this week and then you know I've
got just keeping everyone informed of
the timing so that you've got you create
as much as possible that competitive
situation I think that that turning this
into a process turning fundraising into
a process is something a lot of people
ignore because they want to believe the
stories of oh you know I just happen to
pitch this person we hit it off and all
of a sudden they gave me this money and
it was amazing but the way to do this is
actually build a spreadsheet it's say it
seems crazy but put every single person
you want to talk to in that spreadsheet
and note when you reached out to them
what their response was when you met
with them with the result of that
conversation with probability weights
those conversations both by how much
they're likely to give you and the
likelihood that they're going to give
you that money and then you can start to
decide who you want to spend time on and
now this changes between the seed in the
a in terms of the time that you expect
so if you're talking to angels one or
two meetings coffees right you need to
have like some sort of will actually
will talk about Dec in a second we don't
need that much material for pitching an
angel if you're going in pitching series
a funds like Sequoia you have to have a
lot more together right and you have to
be ready for longer conversations that
are more in depth I really though I
think the the line between seed and a is
kind of blurring as they're shifting
over the years so Polyvore raised our
Series A in 2007 and that was a two and
a half million dollar out or two point
six I think now that seems more like a C
so I think it can bleed I wouldn't I
would I think when you're doing pre
state it's definitely more than angels
but there are plenty of micro VCS as
well as firms like Sequoia that
participate at the seed stage so just
you know you have to be more buttoned up
like the more like I think the larger
the fun-sized but it is interesting I've
definitely noticed a huge shift in the
size of rounds getting bigger and bigger
and then they're starting to be called
as later what used to be a B is is a
write the price at which they're done is
more equivalent
I mean seeds are now being done at
prices that are significantly higher
than a is we're done even three years
ago now that's not always the case right
that happens to be the case in the hot
house of Silicon Valley especially if
you're doing something like YC prices
will be higher than they might be
otherwise or if you're you know a
well-known founder things like that but
I think people who get hung up on the
amount of money you're raising or the
price at which you raise are doing a
disservice to the company so we talked
about this the other day that people
come in like oh I have to raise five
million at fifteen for my feet why right
you're actually probably hurting the
chances of your company by raising too
much money too fast because you're
setting the hurdles for your company way
too high you're not in some competition
to try to have the biggest valuation
right like you need to independent of
everyone else in the market
all your competitors like you need to
think about what is the business plan
that you have what are the milestones
you need to achieve kind of you know at
and then what's maybe 12 to 18 months of
runway or what's the money you could use
to accelerate that plan right think
about it that way and then you know try
to minimize dilution right but the end
of the day like if you're going to be
worth billions of dollars or hundreds of
millions of dollars though sometimes
people over optimize on valuation if you
think about all the things you could be
thinking about like the valuation in the
terms the person that you're working
with the individual partner and then
maybe the reputation or the the firm
that you work with and the brand and
within the firm I think the two things
to look at are of the firm's network as
well as the community of founders that
you step into right because as much as
like getting help from your peers who
are other founders and other CEOs and
rubbing shoulders with like really
amazing founders who help you out then
also elevate your game like that's
really really important that's really
something to look for yeah I think that
the the research ahead of time on
whoever you're talking to is help you
yeah and people don't do it if you walk
into meetings colder people start
talking to investors or prospective
investors knowing nothing about what
they want what they've invested before
you know what their interests are and
it's amazing how important those
personal connections are and that
knowledge people really do react well
when you know something about them when
you don't expect them to just bring
everything to you yeah remember it's a
two-way street right it's a partnership
like you said right I mean I think the
same goes in the other direction right
like if you walk in and your investors
like what's your name again and like
what do you do and like have not
prepared at all like that's also kind of
at that time so you know interesting you
know it's a two-way street like your
interview you're evaluating your
investors as much as they're evaluating
you you want someone who's going to be
hard-working who you feel comfortable
with who can be your first phone call
right like startup like I said it's just
like rollercoaster epik high's epic
glows like in your epic lows like you
want someone who's going to be a shock
absorber and help you through that not
hit the panic button there yeah it's
like all run around like chickens with
our heads cut off and panic and then
make you make it worse for you make it
worse for your team you want some
who's going to have seen downs before
knows what to do we help you out of them
and then also when you're at your epic
high you don't want someone who's just
like Rara cheerleader because there's
always something around the corner that
could you know tank you so you want
someone who's sort of a sparring partner
right who like says like have you
thought about this someone who pushes
you and challenges you to go even even
greater so that's something that's
certainly part of our philosophy is for
members and Koya yeah you know one of
the one of the hardest things to do for
investors actually is to give good
feedback when things are going well that
isn't about oh my god you're going to
kill it it's going to do that because
I'll tell you as a founder you want to
hear the best story of yourself right
you believe the best story of yourself
right you believe the best story of your
future and it feels so good when an
investor as fancy investor comes in says
ah you're totally right you are going to
conquer the world and that advice is
super easy to listen to because it's
just a confirmation bias thing right on
the other hand don't want an investor
who comes in and just beats you up over
everything you do and finding that
medium in the relationship and finding a
relationship where both sides can have
that conversation is huge when ISO
Sequoia was one of my investors and
Brian Shire and I used to do this and he
was super supportive about the good
things and on the things that needed
fixing he didn't yell at me but he
pointed them out logically oh that's
actually a good point that's why he was
a valuable investor and I think a lot of
investors refuse to do that because they
just want to be best friends and I think
investors want to be your best friend
not that's not a knowledgeable model
yeah I mean it can be kind of tempting
like you but I think that ultimately
isn't good in the long run for you or
for your company I think be the other
model that's not great is the person
who's totally uninvolved you know you
like you you want your investors to work
hard for you too right so that's another
sort of bad model what's it worth
another oh the one who's too involved
who wants to like tell you exactly where
your UI and your buttons need to go and
like you know sometimes things like well
my sister or my daughter uses your
product and blah blah blah blah blah and
sometimes that feedback can be sent in a
constructive way but if it's you know I
got this one data point for you
I don't know anything about your product
and I think you should do this and being
very prescriptive about that's not good
you perfect yeah yes our investors need
to know what their relationship does in
company yeah here's here's a may be
counterintuitive tip try not to take
office space in your investors offices
for a long time this is this thing
that's like really tempting because hey
there's some free office space and hey
there's this perk that you get with it
or come work in our accelerator an
incubator
you don't want your investor over your
shoulder all the time it really inhibits
culture and crazy things right because
if you know that your investor is going
to come look at your spreadsheet or look
at your product you're not going to try
the super weird crazy idea that you had
because it needs a little room to to
grow into bloom oh good thing I guess I
think you can I think yeah if it's going
to be an investor comes over and like
stands over your computer and like says
like 110 that's Reggie definitely
definitely not but I think there are
models where you can get office space
and not have that relation because many
times investors are like running around
to also just talking about a company
said they might not be there and the
other thing is if you're you've got
another company in the same space with
you that can be really awesome right
because then you've got a peer group
maybe I do they're not super competitive
but you get that founder to founder
support in that camaraderie and I think
that's a big that's a big a good reason
to sometimes take your own yeah I think
yeah they're they're two sides of that
one one of the things you said really
jumped out at me because it's something
that we work on a lot with our founders
is this idea of being able to clearly
communicate the problem and what your
solution is why is that valuable so you
have to remember that you know your
problem cold right like whatever space
you're in the problem you're solving you
spend like hours and hours thinking
about it and you're talking to someone
who may not know anything about your
space in fact I experienced this a lot
at Polyvore because the Pali word is the
fashion and shopping app targeted at
women and 94% of investors are male so
it couldn't rely on you know when I
pitched an app saying imagine an app
where you could buy dresses all day you
know you know 94% of our value why would
I want that it sounds terrible I hate
shopping so it just didn't work so you
had to come up we had to come up with a
way to communicate
that really clearly so sometimes it's an
analogy sometimes it's you you know
you've draw it a persona this is your
user this is their problem use a real
customer for example for me what we did
is for Polyvore we we were trying to
explain an analogy so what we did is we
took a stack of fashion magazines like
the Vogue September issue which is like
this thick all the September issues we
took them we threw them on the table and
we said this stack of magazines is like
300 million dollars of revenue in one
issue right now imagine that on the
internet and people are like oh I get
that
so the sort of an analogy and then we
showed graphs you know and so you have
to think about your audience right if
it's a space that they don't understand
you really have to take more time to
explain the problem you're solving to
use the customer you're you're solving
for and then from there you can explain
your solution I think a lot of people
just jump directly to the solution I'm
like wait what are you solving for I
don't I don't understand how fish
farming works why would I know it would
sell meaning you just use that to just
know your audience yeah that um that
communication thing I'm guessing you've
all been working on this with your TAS
and group leaders in terms of
encapsulating what you do in a sentence
if possible and it seems a little
esoteric because oh you know I'm
building this big complex thing why
should I have to boil it down and what
it is is it's really just this
exercising condensing and clarifying
thought and what we found in what we've
seen again and again is the best
founders can communicate clearly and can
adjust their explanation for whoever
they're talking to such that it is
meaningful and this changes right this
is different for the engineer that
you're pitching and the investor you're
pitching and the customer that you're
pitching and telling your parents what
you do so they get off your case about
the fact that you're not going to work
at Google but working on a crazy startup
LIF you have to be able to contextualise
for people but that clarity of thought
in the end is is a real defining factor
when you're going in and pitching and I
also say it's one of the things that
tells you that you're ready to go raise
money right and I think this is really
tricky when do I know that my idea that
I've been working on this project that
I've been playing with on the side is
good enough to go raise money and I
think one of the things that you can
actually describe it and why it's
valuable
sinked li and it doesn't take lots of
jargon and a whiteboard to explain all
the different dynamics yeah I think it
also says something about a skill that's
actually really important when what in
being a founder which is can you take a
big hairy complex problem and then break
it down into simpler problems like just
how you'd like to take a program you're
writing a program and you decompose it
to different functions like if you can
take something big and break it down
into subproblems and solve those then
you know that's kind of what you have to
do with your company right like it's
whatever problem you're trying to solve
is probably quite large very complicate
all these moving pieces can you figure
out how to break them into smaller
things and then solve them individually
and that skill is just being able to do
it with your with your pitch deck and
being able to explain this thing you're
working on or been working on through a
few years and condense that down like
that is actually very important it's
like a hell of an important skill for
building startup I think for the last
hop it will we'll dig into and honestly
fundraising could take up days of
conversation in terms of case studies
and role-playing how you do it and
unfortunately we can't do that now but I
think the the the next point for all of
you is you build your companies is
really figuring out when you're ready to
talk to investors and I've mentioned it
briefly for a second but this is a
really curious thing to figure out so
how do you know that you're ready to
raise around to financing how do you
know that you're ready to take someone's
money so I think you might be better to
talk about that one at the
friends-and-family stage and that that
very early stage you know and I think
you don't want to like when you're I
think a startup is like I said it's hard
right it's not something you just kind
of it's not as glamorous as one might
think
there's a lot of like a grunt work that
goes into it so I think having a
commitment to an idea that you can
imagine doing for quite a long time like
we said it takes many many years first
started to become successful I think to
me that's one of its the tipping points
into being able to stay here for your
friends and family hey mom can I have
ten thousand dollars and to be able to
you know know that you might not and I
can't all likelihood you won't give that
back to her right so there's got to be
enough
personal commitment that power describes
a very first milestone I don't maybe you
have more thoughts on that one I think
that's exactly right it's kind of a
fuzzy decision point but it's just this
thing in your head where at some point
the balance of evidence says I want to
work on this for real full time and I'm
okay losing moms or grandma's or my
brothers 10 or 10 grand or 50 grand
like that's probably 98 percent chance
that's just going to go poof and if
you're ok with that
from like a thought-through perspective
and not just I mean some people are
cavalier with their friends and families
money but if you're ok with that because
you really want to commit to something I
think that's the time to go do it yeah
and then as your company grows there
become these other things there are
certain milestones and metrics you know
if you're building a fast business and
you get to a million dollars in ARR and
you're growing at something like 20% to
30% a month you might be ready for a
series a like all this stuff those are
some times right in terms of the next
round of financing but even those are
all like fuzzy lines you can never look
at someone else's experience fundraising
and saying oh that
perfectly ports over to me so I think it
actually plays out forward at every
point in time there is a balance of
evidence that makes you decide that you
are ready or that make someone else
decide that you're ready and they come
and hand you a check I think that's what
Sequoia one of the things the quota does
really well is they'll lean in on a deal
before the founder even realizes that
they're necessarily ready to be like we
think you're amazing and ready we want
to fund you isn't that what happened it
was part yet what happened to us when at
our seed round it's something that's
happened to friends of mine who have
been funded later by Sequoia so anyway
if you are our you know get to the point
where you're ready to raise money or
have other questions about it just email
Jess I think it's Jay Leah
Jess it's the question category I can
talk and I think we've got time for a
few questions in the room and you could
obviously always email me or email YC
I'm Erin ARL in it Y Combinator com
yeah this takes up a lot of time and a
lot of thought and unfortunately
actually fundraising takes up a lot more
time and thought that it should because
it seems like something that should be
systematic but it's actually chaos which
really confuses people at speech
especially people who are logically
brained yeah since the fundraising
strategy you should be like 50 companies
like photo 50 in the same time which
should be due to no over a month or two
or what's the right approach in terms of
Murata running the press with death yes
so the question was what's the right way
to run a process in terms of reaching
out to firms or individuals if you have
a list of 50 do you do it sequentially
or in parallel basically I would say do
it in parallel like everyone to the
starting gate at the same time because
one of the things you you want to create
a competitive dynamic and best way to
create a competitive dynamic is to have
a lot of people trying to do the same
thing at once right so you want to
narrow gate a lot of people trying to
push through it
the only situation when that one which
that isn't true if you have like a super
friendly investor who you know really
well and you think you can get them to
jump the gun and you can like sort of
threaten them and say like ah you know
I'm about to go out and talk to a lot of
people but I'd rather not spend the
effort building a deck and if you can
trigger them to jump in it works
sometimes if you're good enough applying
it but that's really hard that's like
next level you stop yeah in the back the
question so you mentioned that angel
investors are a shorter timeframe as in
the series answers the investors or a
longer timeframe on the topic of process
you know if you were going after Tuesday
or your angel like how many more
meetings or what kind of timeframe do
you think it takes from when you decide
to start that process to when you might
expect to have a result yes let me
repeat a question when you take it up so
the question is what is the timeline and
what is the process for different stages
of investing from the investor's
perspective I would say I wouldn't think
about it just as angel versus firm
I would think maybe a little bit about
how much you're trying to raise like if
you're trying to raise a two and a
$50,000 or $750,000 round and you're
mostly talking to individuals and angels
then
that it can often be just a conversation
a slide deck helps who doesn't always
have to happen when you're getting to
seed so maybe like anywhere from one to
two and a half then you can expect both
from like the micro VCS as well as like
the fantail Road investors probably one
or two meetings right and that can
happen within week like for us it could
definitely be within a week or just just
two meetings I don't know about you guys
well I mean your process will be
different now and then when you get to
an A then you might probably will happen
with a firm is you might have one
meeting with the first person a second
meeting with multiple partners and then
the full partner meeting right not every
firm requires unanimous not every one
week not every firm requires that
everyone sees it but that also tells you
a little bit about how that firm is run
is it more of a team sport or an
individual sport kind of firm so that's
what I would say would be the cadence
and then it's really just about
scheduling like can you get those three
meetings done in a week in two weeks
great firms will be able to move fast
though yeah you will be amazed at how
far timelines can compress in a hot deal
and how long they can stretch out in a
cold one and one of the really
interesting things is if you think about
the incentive dynamic for an investor it
is in their best interest to wait as
long as possible
before making a decision if they can
because they just gather more and more
evidence so but as a founder that's bad
for you so you have to juggle those
things one more one more
any questions
awesome you all know how to fundraise
that's great thank you so much all right
I think I'm the last person between now
and lunch and now and maybe just summer
right
somewhere exams so I'll try to be quick
my name is Ali Roy Ghani subject of my
talk is had to succeed long term and
I've been amazed I was watching some of
the videos that you guys saw and reading
up on some of the notes you guys have
heard from some amazing people Emmitt
shear and Michael Seibel and Aaron Levie
etc talking about how to build a great
product and out of the Angelyn Stewart
Butterfield about how to come up with
ideas and measure success
Peter Reinhart about product market fit
the note Khosla about hiring and
building teams
it's an incredible list of people and
now from just and Aaron about the
tactics of fundraising I'm here to talk
about a topic that's perhaps more
slippery and abstract than any of the
topics you guys have heard about so far
and that topic is leadership and in
particular I wanted to answer the
following question what do you have to
do to be a great leader and hopefully it
goes without saying that that learning
to be a great leader is pretty
fundamental to long-term success and the
reason is pretty simple if you're going
to succeed in building a really
successful startup there's no really no
way around having to hire a lot of
people and motivating and aligning them
and getting to achieve something much
bigger than you could ever achieve on
your own so there's really kind of no
way around learning how to be a great
leader if you want to succeed and for me
the question really starts the most
important initial question to ask is the
following when you study leaders are
great leaders largely similar to one
another or are they really different
and I remember when I was sitting at
Stanford I was an undergrad and a
Business School student here and I
remember sitting in business school and
if you'd asked me that question I would
have said pretty clearly that I think
there's kind of a single personality
trait like leaders are all pretty much
the same and either you had those genes
or that sort of leadership mojo or if
you didn't then you better kind of work
on changing your personality traits
around so you could exhibit some of
those leadership personality traits so
you could be a be a leader and this
question for me was largely an academic
one until after business school I
started working at Pixar the animation
studio and had the extreme good fortune
of working with four people four leaders
that I consider extraordinary and these
four people were Steve Jobs who is our
CEO Ed Catmull who was Pixar's founder
and was the president of Pixar when I
joined John Lasseter who was Pixar's
chief creative officer and Bob Iger who
was the CEO of Disney who acquired Pixar
in 2006 the surprising thing for me
about working with these leaders was
that they couldn't have been more
different in terms of their personality
their temperament their style and really
just the way they went about doing their
jobs and I want to tell you a little bit
about each one of them with the aid of a
picture that's John Lasseter John was an
X is an extroverted artist he is he
studied cartoons he went to animation
school he's boisterous and fun-loving he
loves toys and he has a massive toy
collection you can see part of that
behind him he's emotional he's energetic
you could always read how he felt on his
face he loves wine and good food he had
dozens of hobbies outside of work he
didn't manage his time particularly well
and was always over committed and he
always showed people a lot of love the
people around him he gave everyone hugs
and he wore Hawaiian shirts every day
ed catmull on the other hand was an
introverted scientist he had a PhD he
studied computer graphics at University
of Utah and graduated in 1974 with the
dream to one day make an animated film
on a computer
he was quiet thoughtful exceptionally
calm never reactive he was hard to read
and decipher he was really
health-conscious he kind of lived his
life the right way he didn't drink he
didn't smoke just ate well and his
primary hobby outside of work believe it
or not was to go on week-long silent
meditation retreats you guys all know
about Steve he was a college dropout he
never really worked for anyone in his
life he was a magnetic presence in
meetings walking around he was intense
he was impatient he was extraordinarily
quick on his feet he was not really
prone to bonding with people or showing
love or affection you certainly never I
never saw him give anyone a hug at work
he could say really pointed things he
was aggressive he was always in a hurry
and he was in a hurry to get to the
answer
he had this energy about him and a
clarity of thought and communication
that was really remarkable and then
finally bob iger bob was the CEO of
Disney
he had unlike Steve spent more than 30
years at the same company before he
eventually became the CEO he was
diplomatic is genteel he was patient
wise calm he had gravitas he exude it a
trustworthiness and honor that you
wanted to be around and follow and he
had really really high emotional
intelligence here's a picture of the for
them on the day we announced Disney's
acquisition of Pixar when I look at this
picture I think to myself these four
guys work extremely well together and if
they'd been each other in high school or
in college there's no way they would
have ever been friends you had an artist
and a scientist a hippie and an athlete
and age
would not have run in the same circles
so working with these guys taught me a
lot and it kind of led me to my personal
first insight about leadership which is
that there's no single personality type
for great leaders there's really no
single model and this is actually really
great news if you think about it because
it means that people of varying
personality types can all strive to be
great leaders you're not you don't
there's not a gene set or a certain
personality type that you know allows
you to be a great leader or disqualifies
you from being a leader but the other
implication of this insight is that in
your quest to become a leader of your
startup or even or even a bigger
aspiration for leadership you have to be
yourself you have to be authentic you
can't try to be someone else or copy
someone else's personality or style and
hope to be a great leader you can't try
to be like Steve Jobs and the reason for
that is that as humans were actually
really highly evolved at detecting
inauthenticity and other people and we
don't follow people we find to be
inauthentic so this kind of leads to my
second insight that I wanted to share
which is despite the variability and
personalities despite the fact that
really all personality types can be
great leaders all great leaders have to
do three things exceptionally well the
first is that great leaders think and
communicate clearly as a leader you have
to paint a compelling vision for the
future that other people can understand
and follow and this is the case if
you're a three person startup and you're
trying to motivate your co-founders or
early employees and it's even more the
case when you're a hundred person
company a thousand person company and so
on and the key thing about communication
as a leader is that simplicity of
communication is vital
I remember marveling at Steve Jobs
ability at Pixar
to take the most complicated problem we
were discussing and be able to simplify
it to its core essence break something
complicated apart into what really
mattered and what she should approach
something first second third it was like
we were all sitting in darkness and
there was one guy who had a lantern and
that was Steve and because of that
because he had clarity and could explain
something in a way that you could
understand and sounded right you would
follow him the other example I love on
simplicity is an example from Jeff Bezos
of Amazon he once said that in Amazon's
retail business which now encompasses
almost every category if not every
category of products on earth he said
only three things mattered first low
prices second broad selection and third
fast delivery these three things were
the only things that consumers cared
about and they would always care about
those three things
so anything that an Amazon employee
would do to improve Amazon's performance
in those three areas was aligned with
Amazon strategy and that simplicity has
been there at a bedrock of Amazon's
retail strategy from the beginning
that's great communication
now obviously Bezos and jobs set a
pretty high bar and I'm not here to try
to teach you to be any of those guys but
I can tell you that if you want to
improve as a communicator the first
thing you should do is to step back and
give yourself more time to think even
Steve Jobs used to tell us that when he
was at his best running both Apple and
Pixar half of his time half of his
schedule was unscheduled meaning it
wasn't filled with meetings with other
people he created time in his calendar
to be able to think and that's going to
be really hard when you guys start your
startups you're it's going to be
frenetic your time is going to be you're
going to be pulled in a million
directions and it's going to be very
very difficult to actually devote time
to just thinking I don't mean answering
email I mean time to think and plan
ahead and plan your communication what
are you going to say how are you going
to explain what you think in a clear way
and so my best advice on this is force
your to yourself to take as little as an
hour a day or an hour every other day at
the beginning and try to grow that
amount of time on your calendar that
you're devoted just to thinking go for a
walk sit at your desk
whatever you do that helps you get
clarity take that time you can get
better at communication some people have
natural gifts but anyone with practice
and we're giving themselves time to
think can get better and the core
insight here is that clarity of thought
always precedes clarity of language
second thing all great leaders do is
they show great judgment about people so
you heard Vinod Khosla a few weeks ago
say that the first ten people you hire
into your startup or absolutely critical
and he's right and when you grow your
startup you have to have great judgment
not only about the people you hire into
sort of individual contributor roles but
even more so the people to whom you
decide to give authority and power the
people you decide to promote and to make
managers and to make into leaders and if
you show bad judgment there if you pick
the wrong people if you bring the wrong
people under your company you can never
grow into a great leader and like
communication you can actually improve
and develop your intuition about people
practice and experience again help here
and so as you guys start your companies
many of you will likely be hiring people
for the first time and so here's my
advice don't rush it take the time to
get to know the people you're hiring
ideally start with co-founders and early
employees who you already know it's
important to be aligned from a values
perspective it's not just can this
person code or can this person get the
job accomplished you want to try to hire
people for the long term spend time to
get to know them you know it's not
unusual when people at larger startups
are hiring their first members of
leadership that they spend ten twenty
thirty hours with the person before they
decide to hire them
so spending time to get to know someone
is very very important and trying to
bond with them on values like what do
they really care about are you guys
aligned do you think you can get along
well in the long term evaluate that as
well as their competence and the second
thing is very important in developing
your intuition is try to meet people who
are absolutely great at what they do
even if you can't hire them in order to
develop your own understanding of what
great is again I could give you lots of
examples of founders who spend a lot of
time doing this but the more people you
meet the more great people you meet you
fine-tune your ability to detect those
characteristics and other people finally
a lot of hires don't work out no matter
how well you do it you're going to have
to change people out you're going to
have to ask people to leave make sure
you do that quickly make sure you're
courageous about it and make sure that
you reflect on the lessons learned every
time someone doesn't work out and also
every time someone works out make sure
you're reflective about your own process
and how you've decided to to bring
people into the company and who you
decide to promote into more bigger
leadership roles last insight great
leaders have exceptional personal
integrity and commitment integrity means
standing for something that's important
bigger than yourself it means having a
mission to accomplish that is much
greater than your own personal wealth or
fame it means avoiding behavior that
would erode trust in all of us things
like favoritism or conflicts of
interests or using inappropriate
language or having inappropriate work
relationships the key test for me is if
you consider if all of your
communications all of your emails all of
your verbal communications that you have
with those around you if they were all
transparent to everyone would you be
embarrassed by anything you've done or
said and really you should try to hold
yourself to that bar commitment means
making your work making your startup
to a life mission in a way that inspires
other people it means giving it your all
that's inspiring
when people see others when people see
leaders motivated by a big purpose and
giving it their all to accomplish that
purpose it's motivating in and of itself
and when you think of the opposite when
you see someone who is motivated by
selfish ends who is cutting corners who
is slacking off who is showing ethical
weakness
those are not people you want to follow
so if you want to be a great leader it's
really important to hold yourself to the
spark so I wanted to leave you guys with
the last inside I have and a piece of
parting advice ultimately if you want to
measure a great leader by one thing I
think the most important success metric
for a leader is trust and Trust as a
squishy concept and in the way I'm using
it I mean it almost in a 360-degree
sense the job of every leader is to
build trust is to build trust and
employees and investors and customers
and users and building trust is both an
art and a science the science part of
it's fairly fairly easy it means when
there is an empirical question to answer
when you have to think through what is
the technology we should build or the
product direction we should go in or the
or what sort of partnership we should
strike in the marketplace like you've
got to be right about those those things
a lot right if you it's a question of
competence and it's also a question of
confidence when it comes to the your
people judgement are you good at Detroit
people choices you make both hiring and
promotion the art of trust is more
difficult it's about showing empathy
having good timing choosing the right
words dealing with the right different
people in the right ways and it's about
the integrity and commitment that I
mentioned striving for something bigger
in yourself than yourself rather than
being selfish or self-centered and when
you see a leader who has incredible
trust think about in your personal life
the people you follow in your life
whether it's your friends or family
members etc think about who you have
deepest level of trust or in your life
outside of maybe outside of your parents
and it's likely that those same people
are people you would listen to and
follow because Trust is such a strong
bond so here's my parting parting advice
at every step is you guys move forward
build your startups startup may succeed
it may fail you'll try it again etc
you're going to have hard times and and
hopefully good times always try to
optimize for trust you're going to have
a lot of hard decisions to make you're
going to you're going to if you scale a
start-up you're going to have to fire
people you're going to have to admit
mistakes to your employees and to your
customers you're going to have to say no
to people because you disagree with
their ideas try to view every challenge
you guys face as leaders as an
opportunity to increase the trust that
people have in you and always as you're
evaluating one course of action versus
another my best advice is to ask
yourself which path will generate more
trust in you as a leader and always try
to choose that path thank you very much
I'm happy to take questions or not yeah
you never mentioned where you learn how
to communicate so clearly or just a
natural column you know Steve as you
guys know started off very early as an
entrepreneur and you know there's a
great interview of him if you guys
haven't watched it with Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates together and one of the
things that Steve talks about he said
one of the things that Bill and I have
in common is we were always very early
on the youngest people in the room and
how hard that was and sort of what a
trial by fire that was to try to as the
youngest person in the room convince
other people that you're right so I
think in his case he had years and years
of practice before you know I ever met
him I'm not I don't know if he had any
particular techniques I'm sure a lot of
these gifts came naturally but Proctor
definitely helps and and being around
people who are great at it and observing
them and holding yourself to a high bar
really helps there how do you repair
broken trust me people not certainly
something you did on ethically but
people make mistakes an acumen car truck
how do you repair that I think the most
important thing you have to do is to
acknowledge your mistake and to and to
talk about it you know
brushing onto the carpet or hoping that
people won't notice or people will
forget is a natural human instinct but
it's not the right thing to do and so I
think the first step starts with being
able to admit it you're absolutely right
everyone makes mistakes and most people
are forgiving of mistake but they they
want I think people want to see that you
have you're like them you have some
humanity and that you can accept when
you've made a mistake that you're open
to feedback all these things are really
actually important so don't feel like if
you've made a mistake or goof something
up help talking about it and admitting
it makes you weaker or that shows lack
of leadership it's actually usually the
opposite it usually builds trust to see
people be honest about mistakes that
they've made and to see people have the
self-awareness to realize that they've
made a mistake
we take one more yes you can't this one
driver behind those four people's
motivation
oh yeah for sure well it's hard for me
to speculate well I'll just talk about
John and Ed because I know them the best
John was motivated I think first and
foremost by making great films that
brought families together and you know
would last forever you know he used to
say that what other film other than Snow
White can anyone name that was made in
1937 I hope I got though you're right
but is it the thirties and he said if we
do our jobs well you know these films
will live forever and he was also
motivated frankly by just like having
fun doing what he did I mean he that
that guy really you know squeezed all
the joy he could out of life and I think
those were probably his from my
observation some of his biggest motive
motivators in Ed's case I think Edie
that is a great learner and a sinker I
think what motivated him was trying to
create an organization that could
repeatedly be successful repeatedly
produced great films and he kind of
became an organizational thinker he of
course also wanted to make great films
and you know he's also a technologist so
he cared a lot about the you know the
software we were we were building but I
think fundamentally he wanted to try to
figure out how to make Pixar this sort
of almost almost impossible continue
it's almost impossible streak of
creative success build an organization's
able to repeatedly be successful and
understand why and how that was so at
least this but yeah the motivations did
differ I think there was some some
definitely some shared value some shared
aspirations but each of them had a
different a different specific motivator
yeah all you mentioned that you look at
the feature the early rise to the most
likely will end go
so we're kind of like on the earliest
stage I think so it's almost like high
school yeah and in the future join them
together of your own they won't get
together you gotta like balance getting
people of diverse backgrounds like that
together well I would say you shouldn't
do that when you're when you're early
start up I mean you should hire people
who can first of all that you're
connected with and you can work with
well and you think and get the job done
the point about their diversity had to
do with for all of you in the room I'm
sure there are many personality types
here all of you in the room your
personality type whether you're
introverted or extroverted whether you
have a more silly personality a more
serious personality whether whatever
you've studied whatever your background
is I don't think personality type
disqualifies you from being a being a
great leader or becoming a great leader
that was really the point not that every
company should strive to hire for people
as diverse as them as their first
employees that probably you're right
probably a mistake yeah okay okay thank
you
[Applause]